let's go next to
stephanie in texas stephanie you're on
the air
stephanie in texas you're on the air
please unmute and you'll be able to talk
to me hi hello hello can you hear me hi
yes i can
hi thanks for taking my call
pleasure um and i owe you an apology
actually i tried calling a couple months
ago and i got so excited that instead of
unmuting my call i hung up on you so i
apologize for that oh no so anyway and i
also wanted to um uh just let you know
that we're not all crazy here in texas
but just how crazy how crazy are things
in texas right now
um and i wanted to ask you
thank you for the um you did a piece on
uh the murder charges being dropped
against a woman who tried to seek an
abortion yes um and i you know there's a
lot of things i could
there's a lot of things i'm trying to
like you know to ask you about because
there's a lot of things going on here
right now but that's one of the ones i
think that's really first and foremost
and do you think that that's something
that um might i'm hoping my hope is
it'll lose steam over time as people
maybe get faced with these more if more
charges come up and people start
realizing it's more of a you know a wild
goose chase to some extent do you think
it's going to do in your opinion do you
think it's going to start being
less of an issue or do you think it's
become people are going to try and push
it more i think people unfortunately
stephanie i think the whole charges for
abortions thing i think it's going to be
a new tool that we're going to see a lot
of and in particular in late june the
supreme court
is going to issue a decision on a state
abortion case
and their decision could effectively
overturn roe v wade if that happens
there are 22 states that essentially ban
abortion those laws will then become the
law of the land and i think you're going
to see tons of people charged criminally
for seeking abortions and it's going to
be a dystopian nightmare
yeah and it's unfortunate because you
know obviously the roe v wade is a huge
tool that people have been able to take
advantage of and it's just not
you know i'm
i'm
hoping
that that won't be the case but yeah
unfortunately like you said in june we
kind of have a deadline here now um have
you interviewed beto o'rourke yet or um
is that something that i've if you have
have i missed it and if you haven't do
you plan on doing that he's not been on
we're interested in having him on so far
he's not shown any interest in being on
so if people want to tweet to beto and
say hey okay go to the david pakman show
we would love to have him
yeah i think i follow him and i've also
volunteered to phone bank and uh and uh
not knock on doors for him so hopefully
i'll get some word out there but yeah
he's just i'm hoping that he'll he'll
have some some
pull if he gets elected hopefully it's
just it's just been so kind of crazy and
i get so frustrated people say we don't
like it and move you know that's a
really um you know generic thing to say
to people because we can't just move
it's like our home and our business is
here and people have families and
everything yeah it's it's really crazy
for sure stephanie listen
can you get a good bagel in texas or is
that impossible
um actually
uh
uh you know
i guess it depends i if i want to go
drive through for bagel i go to the
einstein brothers which i'm sure is like
you know pretty pretty basic but um i
make my own bagels in the air fryer
actually it's pretty funny like i make
them with um i have a air fryer and i
found a really good recipe for
um it's not like your traditional bagel
so it's not it's a little bit more like
a
it's a little moister it's like i use
greek yogurt and flour so it's just like
three ingredients basically and i do my
airfryer and it sounds more like that it
sounds more like a cake than a bagel it
kind of is but it's like it's really
good because it's like you know it's
higher in protein and a little bit
better for you than like all the carbs
in the regular bagels sure sure
we're just all right stephanie well all
kinds of crazy it sounds complicated
down there but i appreciate you calling
in yeah well just kind of keep us in
your thoughts and follow us because
we've got a lot of interesting things
going on here absolutely bagels aside a
lot going on in texas there's stephanie
from texas 100 thank you very much uh
all right we're going to take a quick
break but i'm still taking more of your
calls just hang on we will be right back